why do you hate Tesla I bought a Model S
plaid last year everyone got car sick in
the back they all felt like throwing up
cuz the regenerative breaking the car
and the concept and the technology is
brilliant but the actual build of them
is terrible door frames are misaligned
like all the stuff so I bought the model
S I let my cousin used it to go to San
Diego and the motors blew on him on the
highway as he was driving down keep in
mind this car was a week old and I bring
it into Tesla and I'm like just give me
a new one it's got like 50 M on it they
had the car for like 9 weeks fixing it I
was like this car is a week old you're
not give me a loner Porsche would never
do that how would they not give you a
loner I don't know